he leads the major leagues in runs
scored right now he is part and parcel
of the best offensive machine in
baseball he is George Springer of
Houston Astros here on the Richard show
how are you George
how you doing I am doing fine
I got to be honest with you here I know
I might be made to feel old in this
conversation because when I was doing
Sports Center in Bristol I'm assuming
because you're from New Britain about
ten minutes away from Bristol about 17
18 minutes as the crow flies you were
growing up in grade school while I was
doing sports centre correct George oh
yeah yeah I'm I was born and raised
there I was there my whole life and he
has been within my backyard
oh my gosh Wow did you ever like drive
past thinking you know what I want to
play baseball or I want to be on
SportsCenter one day just driving past
the complex there in Bristol George yeah
you know but there's a driving range
that that my dad used to take us do this
right close there I forget what it was
called Hine Valley Pine Valley yes that
that's it that place every single time
you I used to go by and you know see
this big satellite dishes and I had a
bunch of ESPN posters not stuff like
that so yeah I mean it was you know the
goal was to be on on on SportsCenter but
obviously I didn't make that one oh well
I mean come on George I think you I
think I've seen some of your highlights
these days on ESPN MLB Network and you
know left right up and down what you
played at UConn correct walk me through
the process of you going to school and
back to college and and whether you
might have been overlooked at some point
in your life Josh yeah so well I was
about a junior in high school my dad had
told me that if I had the opportunity to
pursue my dream but I can do it and of
course you know as a kid
answered uh dad like that that's the
plan but then he asked me if I had any
other plans that my dream didn't work
out and at the time you know I said no
you know I'm going to do everything
right and and you know I said dream will
come true and I'm gonna play for 25
years and you know he he looked me in
the face and he laughed at me and you
know I'll never forget that and his
point was I have to have a fallback plan
and you know the most important thing in
the world besides you know fighter dream
at the time was was was going to school
and in education and then you know he
told me that school would allow me to
pursue my education but it'll also allow
me to grow you know as a person and as a
player and and such the time came and
thought that that was the decision was
was you know I understood that you know
at the time if if this game didn't work
out I had to have a plan and you know so
I had a something to fall back on and
you know that that would obviously save
my education so I said you know what
that I'm gonna you know I'm going to go
to school no matter what and then you
know hopefully in four years we'll we'll
see what happens and man what has
happened it's been nothing short of
outstanding George I mean not only are
you part of a good young team that has a
bright future you are an all-star and
not just any all-star I mean Bryce
Harper wore a microphone during the game
for an in-game interview for Fox's
coverage of the all-star game and of all
the all-stars for the American League
you're the one who wore the microphone
why did you agree to do that George
um because it's fun you know stuff like
that to me it's great oh I like to give
fans and to give people that the
perspective of the player and all that
stuff like that but for me with it was
for a you know I'm the spokesperson for
saying and you know if
if I can go out there and talk and show
you know these kids and adults that you
know I can put myself out there and not
be concerned about stuttering all that
you know hopefully I can help somebody
and then obviously having a microphone
in my ear and so a microphone on my
chest that day is it imitating but you
know what it's alright so for those who
might not know what say is lay it on me
George
it's the stuttering Association for the
youth and that's why you wanted to put a
microphone on and maybe there's some kid
out there was a problem with stuttering
and here's George Springer of Houston
Astros wearing a microphone on a live
broadcast playing baseball it's an
all-star might inspire somebody with
absolutely you know that the because you
know that some of the message that I
have to people is you know you can't let
anything that you can't control stop you
from being who you want to be and you
know at the same time I can't I can't
tell somebody to go do that if I'm not
willing to put my himself out there and
you know hopefully if somebody saw it he
said you know isn't afraid to speak in
public anymore and now here you are here
calling in the rich eyes and show which
are greatly appreciative George Springer
joining me here what has made everything
seem to click this year with AJ Hinch
and the rest of the group George um for
one you know the veteran leadership of
McCann Beltran and Renick has has has
has made a huge difference were older
now you know if we would play together
as a team for the last three four years
so I I think we understand you know how
each other operates and we understand
you know how to play as a team but but
this most important thing that I've seen
is our having fun at work we're enjoying
the game you know I understand who we
are you know understand what our offense
can do so you know they just go out
there and end and have fun
and designated hitter you did that last
night you've done you've done that only
a handful of times is this something
we're going to see more of for you in
the common weeks to perhaps keep you
fresher
George I don't know no that's obviously
up to skip yeah he stuck me in there
yesterday for the second time and if
it's uh so it's a good blow from playing
this field and you did you just get off
your feet thumb but you know well we
also have a professional hitter that uh
Carlos Beltran though I thought I'm
going to take his position
who's the cut-up on this team when you
say have fun who's the one who leads in
that department George Springer uh I'm
probably the one that that that that
starts it a lot of the times but I can
can honestly say that everybody has fun
you know are always getting on each
other there's there's a it's a
Brotherhood for sure and you know we're
always in there playing PlayStation at
playing card they kind of just enjoying
the time that we have in the field and
then it translates on the field give me
a for example how do you started give me
give me one that I guess would even be
safe for work George not to say that you
might work blue but you know this isn't
my first rodeo you know I've been around
the block New Britain in the rest of it
there's some pranks that get done you
know versus and today we're actually
going to go have a funeral for a
Beltronics gloves because he just played
the field in a while so you know stuff
like that and it's uh it's a lot of fun
well who leads the who leads that that
ceremony who's going to be are you
leading the ceremony for belt Ron's
glove potentially I guess I'll probably
see if Joshua medical wants to do it you
know he he said some funny stuff man
he's he he's a character we got Brian
McCann is also uh uh Nvidia funnier guys
and he's actually to play to it Beltran
longer so we'll see
I'll see who's going to put his glove to
rest today that's great how come you're
not on you're not on Twitter we we
looked at the roster you're one of only
four Astros to not have a Twitter
account why is that George you're gonna
have to hit me on the landline and I'm a
big I just I just don't really care for
it you know I don't wanna work but
really who uses social media at all I'm
just an old-school guy mannequin if I
could have a football I would I don't I
don't I was using my fault right think
what Spotify I was about to say that
George because you sound like Andrew
Luck who does still have a flip phone he
called himself a Luddite last time we
chatted about you know yeah I don't know
I'm just not a big guy you know I don't
I don't really go on the internet I
don't know I guess high today standards
I did considered weird cuz I have a
Twitter and Instagram or Facebook or
anything like that I just I got it you
know I go home and then and join my life
off is real nothing I'm not attached to
my phone is it so let's actually go
through it you know if the phones on the
phone now I actually probably wouldn't
even know there it is I lose my phone
every day and I don't care
Wow so do you watch TV do you know you
don't even watch like Game of Thrones or
anything like that George no no I didn't
say all that okay I didn't said all that
I do watch TV I'm not completely stuck
in the Stone Age I just don't have
twitter or instagram any of that stuff
did you see Game of Thrones last night I
did I was locked in okay you know I've
got Sam Tarly just sitting right here on
the green room couch they've actor John
Bradley Samwell Tarly George come on
yeah yeah that's it do you want to say
hi yeah
say hunter he had a rough few themes on
that one hahaha well he looks great
right here George George he looks great
right now I hope you look better than it
did in the same there you go hey George
you take care man come back on the show
anytime really of love didn't
you know Dallas has been uh Dallas has
been on your your manager AJ Hinch has
been on Carlos Correia called in I feel
like I know you guys so let's have you
back on Jorge oh man hey I'm here is
that hit me on the landline you got it
that's George Springer even though it
sounds like he's bluetooth than on the
foot thank goodness he didn't lose his
phone for this interview it's George
Springer how about that he's wearing a
microphone because he wants to inspire
young folks who have a stuttering
problem but I look at me good for him
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience isn't it amazing
you can download an app with your
thumbprint you should download our app
with your thumbprint